so listen I've been a fan of yours for a
while and I'm curious you've done so
many things if someone has actually
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why
um probably
and my name is Joe because it's a good
very nice film made by a genius director
can launch and filmed entirely in
Glasgow where I where I live
I would recommend that they watch that
you know and and that's the one they
give me the big prize for way back in
the day when they're giving their
Enterprise Channel
so so even if someone doesn't like it
they can go online and they can say
well they give him
oh so I would recommend that one
uh one of the things about this is uh
your character makes a decision to
basically let the elves uh die and I'm
just curious do you personally agree
with that decision or would you have
given them the me thrill uh I absolutely
agree with that this decision the
boarding is all the hell and kill the
elves from the dwarf King dwarf says the
elves deserve everything they get
they're too big literally immense
importantly get ready not the answer I
was expecting but I appreciate the humor
um one of the things about listen I love
the series and I'm Blown Away by the
scale and scope and just everything that
it's like an eight hour movie it's not a
TV show
um what was it like for you actually
because you've been involved in so many
different things what was it like for
you stepping on set for the first time
and realizing what this thing was going
to be
well stay put on first time it was
Kenneth Chucky in the sense that I
hadn't been given the scripts I only got
the scenes that I was in so I'll get no
context I don't know what anyone else is
doing I don't know what size it is I
knew it was big
but then Harry Potter was big I mean so
what big deal you know just because
something's big doesn't mean you see
it's going to be any good
um so I couldn't understand was was
interesting because it's
it's it's like any big sense I've been
in and you you reduce it mentally and
emotionally as an actor you reduce it to
you your cozy your lines and your fellow
your fellow comrades you know your mates
your actors and so you make the world
very very small because you need to
because you're going to climb up a
little bit and if you allow if you allow
the size of something to get to you then
you'll freeze you'll you'll choke your
Panic so it's vital to get to to be
comfortable with your fellow actors and
with the crew and with the director so
personally I would always see any actor
in these big sets is make it very small
have a laugh take the Mickey out of it
don't take it too seriously and that way
come to Serious moments you can explore
the same way as you would if you're in a
no money production there was a guy who
said to me years ago
and I don't normally pay much heat to to
wise folk in the industry telling you
why these things they usually tend to be
text and but this guy did say one thing
it really stopped with me and it was
professionalism is not a standard it's a
state of mind
and he was right because if you're in a
no budget phone you should be given just
as much attention and just amount and
just the same amount of effort and and
and exploration as you do in a big
budget production money shouldn't come
into it so but size shouldn't come into
it so if you have the same attitude and
a low budget production as you're doing
a big budget production then then you'll
have your own working method that's true
to what you're doing and I think that's
something sometimes actors not
necessarily young actors but some actors
let the size of something get to them
and they feel that they should somehow
fill that space
and and that's that's a mistake and
where we were lucky and Lord of the
Rings was the directors made us all feel
very much like it's a low budget student
production they they kept the scale at
the
and and you have to do that because if
you don't you won't get performances
that have no basis in any kind of truth
they're just based on fear because the
actors terrified rightly so the actors
thinking I don't I don't deserve a
big trailer or I've been saying a big
fancy costume who am I you know you you
immediately doubt yourself so we were
really lucky that in this to walk on on
those sets and it not be a big deal you
don't want to look at it you don't want
you want to be familiarize yourself we
are saying in relation to what you're
doing but you don't want to spend too
much time looking at it going wow
this is amazing you don't want to do
that until maybe after the first week
when you're feeling all right
uh you and uh oh I'm
um uh are fantastic together and I'm
just curious how much were you guys
talking before you stepped on set about
your relationship and building a bond
and how much was it just you guys are
good actors and I'd see it's the world
star or the last thing I think we we
cannot can we both know it and we didn't
do any talking about it because of any
of that stuff and we just got on really
well
and we trusted one another so the only
thing I know about acting is never tell
another one to do that's the only thing
I know is it now a director comes in
they can tell you you know more or less
less than that whatever the only thing I
know that I'd say is I would never tell
another actor what to do so if an actor
wants to talk about things absolutely I
don't have any problems but I would
never suggest or move it that's if they
if they're going to be a light bulb I'll
be a lampshade and if they want to build
I'm sure they'll be the label and if
they want to jump between the two during
the scene it's fine by me I mean I love
I love the fact that between the word
action and cut you can go wherever you
go it's it's it's it says Scott
Fitzgerald said about creativity it's a
big block of ice hot stove it'll go
they'll go wherever it goes and acting
for me should be the same just go
whatever it's going to take you you know
some change you do a wet performance and
you cry your eyes out and the next take
you do a dry performance
who knows which one's better
give it and the rest is up to the direct
on the edit on stuff so with Hawaiian
and I we had a really lovely trust and
respect and and other than that we just
played the scenes that was good he's
beautiful he walked with her lovely uh
I'm curious when you how familiar were
you with tolkien's work prior to getting
cast and how much did you feel because
Lord of the Rings is so beloved by so
many people that you wanted to read
everything and learn about the history
so when fans come up to you you could
sort of talk about it although I would
talk no fine would ever come up to me
because I don't have a clue about
talking or as well it totally it totally
passed me by and I'll get mates I love
it and say that I wasn't allowed to
arranged kind of guy I was more
um and I'll do more objections in
Shakespeare in terms of the classes
industrial escape
and a lot of dragons never you know I do
a feeling one way or the other four uh
and I liked I like to first film uh the
Jackson did
um that I don't watch any of the hobbits
or the other ones I didn't know anything
about the world at all but I like the
idea of doing uh well I love the idea I
got in New Zealand I love the idea of
just doing something that involved all
that kind of silliness you know oh I'm
just gonna say you did fantastic work I
really appreciate you giving me your
time and good luck with the rest of your
interviews today thanks Mom so glad you
get to work from home